nos piden seleccionar tres razones que
sean equivalentes a la razón 7 a 6 pausa
en el vídeo y traten de encontrar las
tres razones que son equivalentes a 7 a
muy bien hagámoslo juntos lo que tenemos
que hacer para darnos cuenta de si
tenemos razones equivalentes es
multiplicar o dividir las partes de la
razón por la misma cantidad así que
antes de revisar estas opciones por
ejemplo si tengo la razón 7 a 6 y
multiplico 7 por 2 para obtener 14
entonces también tengo que multiplicar 6
por 2 para obtener 12 y 14 a 12 es
exactamente la misma proporción ahora
puede ser que te sientas tentado a
seleccionar 12 a 14 pero esta no es la
misma razón el orden es importante en
una razón ésta podría ser la proporción
de naranjas a manzanas y estaríamos
diciendo que por cada 7 naranjas hay 6
manzanas y no podríamos decirlo de otra
manera de modo que tenemos que descartar
esta opción aunque parece que tiene los
números correctos no están en el orden
correcto
ahora vamos a revisar 21 a 18 para ir de
7 a 21 tenemos que multiplicar por 3 y
para ir de 6 a 18 tenemos que
multiplicar por 3 también así que esto
funciona bien si multiplicamos estos dos
números por 3 obtenemos 21 a 18 así que
voy a marcar esta opción está seguro que
si es equivalente y 42 a 36 bueno para
ir de 7 a 42 tenemos que multiplicar por
6 y para ir de 6 a 36 también tenemos
que multiplicar por 6 de modo que esta
también es una razón equivalente
multiplicamos cada uno de estos por 6 y
mantenemos el mismo orden así que
también marcamos esta razón equivalente
63 a 54 vamos a ver para ir de 7 a 63
tenemos que multiplicar por nueve y para
ir de 6 a 54 tenemos que multiplicar por
9 también una vez más 63 a 54 es una
razón equivalente
y ya hemos seleccionado tres pero vamos
a verificar si ésta funciona o no
entonces para ir de 784 tenemos que
multiplicar por 12 y para ir de 6 a 62
tenemos que multiplicar por 10 y dos
sextos o 10 y un tercio así que está
definitivamente no es una razón
equivalente hagamos otro ejemplo
una vez más nos piden que seleccionemos
tres razones que sean equivalentes a 16
a 12 así que pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolverlo muy bien vamos a revisar
esta primero 8 a 6
a primera vista piensas o estos números
son más pequeños que 16 y 12 recuerden
que para obtener una razón equivalente
pueden multiplicar y dividir estos
números por el mismo número
entonces para ir de 16 hasta 8 tenemos
que dividir entre 2 y para ir de 12 a 6
también tenemos que dividir entre 2 así
que en realidad esto es una razón
equivalente la voy a marcar y 32 a 24
bueno para ir de 16 a 32 tenemos que
multiplicar por 2 y para ir de 12 a 24
también tenemos que multiplicar por 2 de
modo que esta es una razón equivalente
y qué pasa con 4 a 3 bueno para pasar de
16 a 4 tenemos que dividir entre 4 y
para ir de 12 a 3 también tenemos que
dividir entre 4 estamos dividiendo cada
uno de estos números entre la misma
cifra así que esta también es una razón
equivalente
ya seleccionamos tres opciones así que
esencialmente hemos terminado pero
podríamos revisar porque éstas no
funcionan ahora pensemos en esto para ir
de 16 a 12 podríamos dividir entre 4 y
multiplicar por 3 así que eso sería
multiplicar por 3 cuartos y obtendríamos
12 y para ir de 12 a 8 tendríamos que
dividir entre 3 y multiplicar por 2 esto
lo podemos ver como multiplicar por dos
tercios si tenemos que multiplicar o
dividir por números diferentes aquí
entonces esta no es una razón
equivalente y 24 a 16 para ir de 16 a 24
tenemos que multiplicar por déjenme ver
por 1.5 esto que tenemos aquí lo tenemos
que multiplicar por 1.5 y para ir de 12
a 16 tenemos que multiplicar por 1 y un
tercio de modo que no estamos
multiplicando por la misma cifra por lo
que esta no es una razón equivalente
y terminamos